hey everybody and welcome to the Sha
method I am sha mcginness and this is
Peter Brown and today we're going to
play shenmu in continuing observance of
video game history month never forget
perhaps the holiest of months on the
video game calendar not to be confused
with lava month uh QuickTime event month
or other such months I love them months
yeah Daytona USA month that's probably
my favorite um we just watched the
Daytona USA intro on YouTube that's of
no relevance to you but if you haven't
watched it recently it's pretty
inspiring it's pretty inspiring just
listen to it on Loop uh cuz that that
guy who yells
Daytona it's just amazing do that really
well yeah anyways this is Shen this is
shenmu this is a a game for the
Dreamcast that Yu Suzuki made he's one
of the legendary developers at Sega uh
he's sort of one of their guys who
worked on a lot of their early arcade
games and uh I mean this game was pretty
ambitious when it came out yeah no this
game was uh it's one of my all-time
favorite games it holds a very special
place in my heart um I remember being a
young Shan playing this game on
Dreamcast when it first came out and
just being blown away by like the
General open of it cuz I had never
played quite like this before it's
compared to open world games these days
of like a Grand Theft Auto style yeah
it's not as impressive it's very
different there are a lot of walls there
are a lot of loading screens damn walls
so there you know uh but like when it
first came out so many things it did
incredibly like just like the scope of
the game the weather let's talk about
the dynamic weather shall we the voice
acting I know at the time like in 2000
it just felt so special and so fresh and
this I think it's actually the first
time that I'm replaying it since I first
played the game way back when so I'm
almost scared how it might shatter the
illusions of this being some wonderful
game that's aged incredibly well you
should be scared Sean cuz I played some
of this last night and it has not aged
that well no it has not aged that well
but talk to these kids oh
dude do you know any Chinese people I
know
soku you can get a soku eraser out of
this capsule toy machine I see um so the
tiny homunculus told me that I should uh
check out this capsule machine I love
these I will buy one I should buy one
Sean you should describe the uh the
controls for this game for people who
don't remember okay so the Sega
Dreamcast controller let me just there
we go there we go this is what a Sega
Dreamcast controller looks like you'll
notice directional pad analog stick and
some buttons so you run around with with
the analog stick right no no why would
you think that Peter Brown I don't know
I guess modern gaming standards have
taught me that that's the best way to
control a 3D character in a game no you
ignorant fool hold on I have to quit
this screen so I can teach my friend
Peter Brown about the control scheme
basically you move around with the
directional pad so like up on the d-pad
moves forward back will'll do a little
one 80 and then you do these little side
to side movements what if I want to run
now if you want to run you might think
that you need to I don't know use the
analog stick but no analog stick
actually controls the camera really
tight controls with the camera right oh
yeah real tight real fluid controls uh
you hold the L trigger and that's how
you run and then you you do these like
really like hair pin turns uh you can't
you can't do any hair hair pin turns
while running in Shen moo so the control
scheme is like immediately one of those
things that has not aged terribly well
but you know what has aged really well
in shenmu buying a soda at the soda
machine hell yeah hell yeah we're going
to go up to this is like one of those
things that I really loved about the
game when it first came out is it felt
like exploring a small little Japanese
City and I say that having never been to
Japan when I first played this game
right but just like I don't know the
scope of the things like all the little
details that you could do like going to
soda machines going to capsule machines
it just felt it felt really interesting
at the
time and now I'm just slugging this jet
Cola you I always
ey
oh that's delicious so tasty uh as a
reminder you can feel free to join us in
the twitch chat do it on twitch.tv/
Gamespot what who who do we have in
there who are regular oh we got sakumi
I'm sure we got Bob Jones yes we have
Bob Jones
yeah mous Madness eminent stranger Sor
all told there are 642 people and I
can't name them all as long as they're
sakatumi that's what really matters yes
so uh um did you get that capsule toy no
I didn't get my sen Goku capsule toy
didn't you get like Jeffrey I yeah I did
get
Jeffrey toy capsules 100 yen each huh
huh I should buy one I should buy one
TR let's
go what is
it
oh oh it's oh try not to look too
excited Rio take care of your knuckles
dude what you don't like his Twisted
Knuckles oh yeah look at this all right
I'm GNA try one more dice tight tight
sweet I'll add it to my collection maybe
I should get another yes that's a good
idea definitely definitely the addiction
I mean I've got 10,000 Yen these are
only 100 yen a pop and we've got 55
minutes we've got 55 minutes to spend
just dumping yen into this caps cool
that is pretty
cool okay all right I should try again
no Rio you have to avenge your father's
death [__] uh so shenmo you know when
you when you look back on it like at
least for me I was thinking of it as
more of like an action game what I
forgot picking up the controller and
actually playing the game is how much of
an adventure game it is you spend so
much time talking to people looking
around which is sort of Complicated by
the controls a little bit it makes game
feel a little clumsy but yeah but yeah
it's only rarely that you actually
engage in combat like combat is
something that you have to like unlock
into like a significant portion into the
game yeah like at the very beginning I
can't just run around and like smash the
a button and try to kick children in the
face as much as you want to as much as I
would like to that's just not an option
right now for me so for me right now
what we're actually doing at this
portion into the game is uh we are
looking for
Clues as for the um the mysterious man
who killed my father at the beginning of
the game spoiler Rio's father gets it's
true kind of like clobbered to death at
the beginning of the game so Tom hot dog
truck had words with black Carmen Tom
saw lande and suggested I seek
information from Chinese people I feel
do we want to explain the context of
this or do we want to let hot dog truck
Tom kind of just like run wild in
people's imaginations I would like to
introduce people to Hot Dog truck Tom if
that's okay okay all right let's let's
uh Tom's a forgetful man who sells hot
dogs hot dogs down town
doita and uh well that's where we're
headed right
now let's go he's a very interesting
individual Tom he's a great guy he's a
great guy he's a real solid bro he's a
real classy guy yeah he's a guy you
would want dating your sister mhm but
first i'm going to hang out with some
old people in this
park oh it's you don't sound so excited
to see me seems to be better those eyes
much
better um by the way did you find out
anything about that car about that black
car I heard
Chinese who is the best person to ask
about people from China in this town
Chinese people let me think he's going
to say Chinese Chinese restaurant down
in duita don't you the AI Ichi the owner
of that restaurant is
Chinese yeah he's also the of the
Chinese Association yeah asking him yeah
okay we got another lead talk about a
clue all right so just to explain the
context um you start asking around about
this black car which was seen around the
city on the day that your father was
murdered by this mysterious man dressed
in uh traditional Chinese attire lande
lie and so as Rio is walking around
asking people about it he's kind of
connecting the dots and uh he's trying
to find if there might have been a group
of Chinese people driving a black car
and what the significance of that might
be viav his father getting Pummel to
death so we're going to try to find that
out this man knows do you know oh no no
no I just can't now come on I'm not in
the mood to talk now well you're talking
he's having marital issues I
think
flowers ah hello
Rio who's the best person in town to ask
about people from China that would be
the owner of a I know that already skip
skip okay we're going to head to the
Chinese restaurant but first we're going
to find our buddy Tom yeah where the
hell is Tom oh this is the arcade we'll
be coming back here later don't worry
don't you worry don't you worry about
that we will be playing it playing some
hang
on uh This
Way ask that kid what he's up to Hey kid
do you know any Chinese people you like
party let's play baseball all right
sorry maybe later okay oh what no I said
no look at this stupid little kid in the
way he walks I'm going to walk right in
front of him what a dumb piece of [__]
get out of my way kid you bother me
where you going kid oh God heol whoa
who's this tough dude hey excuse me nope
don't mean to talk to you I was trying
to talk to my buddy on the motorcycle oh
your buddy's gone hey kid quit walking
like an
idiot look look at him he's like
floating as if walking on
clouds
amazing oh this guy's got like US
military surplus GE he probably knows
about Chinese
people who's the best person in town to
ask about people from China people from
China who are they was the name of that
place you know that Chinese restaurant
at the far end the
aichi yeah that's it I don't eat there
much but the owner he's Chinese and the
pacing of this dialogue is so hard like
I get so bored it's like sh go move okay
okay you guys are in for a treat so
remember Tom hot dog truck from The
Notebook well this is Tom hot dog truck
from The Notebook did you come up with
anything about people from China sorry
not yet
really come on Tom
really oh it won't even let me talk to
him oh man fine sorry can one of his
pickles I got a trigger a new dialogue
sequence with Tom is this no that's the
world tour oh this is the uh the the
travel agent who might be able to fill
me in on Chinese people because they're
a travel agency and Chinese people
sometimes travel to and from China
so you know you know let's talk to this
guy Excuse me yes yeah I'm looking for
someone who knows about Chinese people
do you know anyone why don't you try the
Chinese restaurant I think we should go
to the Chinese restaurant everybody
wants me to go to the GD Chinese
restaurant sure their employes guess
Chinese thank you very
much don't mind me I'm just going to
walk around your little place mess it up
I can't actually interact with the
environment at all in this game oh what
if I just stood here and stared at
him you there
hey you there hey hey you why don't you
just keep working I'm just going to
stand like
this slowly slowly pan
around do you think this guy's getting
bothered or I don't think he's aware of
your presence he's probably he's
probably totally into it fine
fine I'll go to the Chinese restaurant
the
aichi we're going to solve this murder
within the space of of this single
episode I sure hope so yeah don't worry
we'll get to it
D hey
mister come
on
loading classic
Tom raging at the hot dog truck all
right there's the water dragon good old
water dragon that's a good place
convenience store tomato
H oh no hey wait a
minute hey haki you think you can bump
into me and not even apologize yeah jerk
apologize to Anan not a million years
just beaten
apolog I don't have time for this get
lost that's it you
history like a
boss that's
it what I pressed the
button damn you're pretty
tough eat it get bunch of
dicks what do you know about Chinese
people have time to play your little
games then move along sir yes I'm sorry
you don't mess with me again got
it all right all
right I know QuickTime events so you
guys better just slow your roll hey are
you okay can you get
up wow yeah wow yeah I really took those
dudes to town they were already in a
town but I took them to a I took them to
another town a real painful town
town if you were a Chinese restaurant
where would you
be chinat Town excuse me um sorry can't
talk now talk to you later oh that guy
looked real cool
yeah oh there you
go good old water dragon another water
dragon volume two how many water dragons
are in this GD
Town what we got there you think this
that look this is a barber shop
yes oh these girls are real jerks oh hey
ladies um got a minute you girl like
party get out of my space school
boy that's harsh what just cuz your
friend here is pooping doesn't mean I
can't talk to you come on excuse me put
poop in for whoa hell you think you are
can't you see I'm pooping here can't you
see I'm pooping come on you get away
from me I'm pooping can't a girl pinch
one off in
pieace oh gross but yes she should be
able to do that in
peace it's 1986 Peter come on it was a
different time back
then people just pooped in the streets
there's the 80s what do you
expect excuse me do you guys know where
I can find a Chinese restaurant
hello try it just try it let's go in
in I bet you it's one of those massage
parlors we're going to go into the lapis
lapis oh no to lapis I've been expecting
you nope
nope H you have expect
this oh man I just noped right out of
there not today
lady I W get down with that what's
happening in the chat what's going on R
asking me how many copies of this game I
own just the one just the one you know
what I'm not even going to type it
because I just said it just the one just
the
one okay how many copies do you
own funny bear Burgers here we go I'm
going to get a burger please um hi what
can I get for you what would that smile
off your face another answer who should
I ask about people from China in this
name another answer from China you the
owner of a is there anyone else nope you
the owner is sort of an influential man
in the Chinese Community I see all right
cool do you know where I can find this
restaurant that looks like a tattoo
paror
that is a bar jazz bar Jazz and bar Jazz
and bar definitely going to have to go
back there later wait is that it
nope nightclub
sua
Nana Bob's Pizza
Baron snack Linda it's my favorite kind
of Linda slot house ooh that'll be fun
later
nope maybe it's this only you had a map
if only I had a map yep I think this
might be it Peter are you sure I think
okay let's give it a try it might be
here we go I'm going to walk into these
pants
here they're just hanging pants out
front big wide wide bottom pants
a Ichi Chinese restaurant 1:19 p.m.
December 4th
1986 excuse me my
friend oh hello
yes are there any other Chinese people
around here why do you want to know
about other
Chinese uh that's my business is it
something to do Chinese should ask a lot
of
questions yes oh no not all Chinese
people are bad I understand that but the
only clue I have is that they were
Chinese uhoh that dude is uncomfortable
he's walking out
whoops Buton man back
again you excuse me oh hi there oh hi
he's got his lunch helmet on I'm just
going to go ahead and oh I can't walk
into the kitchen you can talk to them
again please is there anything you could
tell me you say Chinese people around
here but there's quite a lot of them
compared to before we don't really know
the
newcomers I see why don't you tell him
about the three
blades yeah to on the three blades three
blades three blades what are the three
blades it literally refers to three
different BL oh my God that represent
three different trades the barber the
tayor and the cook they all use bladed
tools true the barber uses a razor yes
okay the tailor uses scissors yep and
the cook uses knives are you one of the
three blades I most of the Chinese who
came to Japan were one of the three it
doesn't cost much to set up so you can
start the business quickly people of the
three blades also know each other very
well why does the Chinese guy have an
English accent but the Japanese people
have American accent who are some of the
is that to signify his foreignness
culture culture okay cuz he's from Hong
Kong and Hong Kong at the time wasn't
that the time where
they who's making patches now under the
realm of the queen yes go and ask m cook
and ramen the three blade people know
other Chinese people as well oh there's
also another barber shop the Le Barber
and hair salon but but Le son's father
is in the hospital now I think you
should go R up rough up his father in
the hospital what do you know swear to
me so I should go and speak with my son
eoy son and M puku kin Ramen right yes I
see I see thank you very
much okay time to add that to my hot dog
journal excuse me oh nope didn't mean to
talk to you just meant to look at my
journal three blades
nice men puking Ramen scissors
Taylor okay cool
great let's go find some blades all
right I have a feeling that this murder
is going to get solved before
Sundown let's figure it out might even
have time for some forklift driving
probably not no I don't think
so 2:1
p.m. are you one of the three blades no
you are wearing a cardigan sweater
nobody with a cardig sweater knows how
to wield a blade man I really wish you
could just get on those bikes oh what
get out of my way
deag I'm on a
mission I remember there there was that
barber shop that I thought was a
restaurant where was that that was
around
here do you know the three
blades um what is
it give me a chance wow that
conversation was a real
I think it's down
here
yes you think the water dragon jean
store is where a tailor might work I
don't know but I like that the guy's
wearing an apron the jean store here we
go Barber Shop ding done
done oh what they're not open oh they
open at they open at 10:00 a.m. it's
closed yeah
H excuse me I'm terribly sorry but I've
been too tired lately I'm not in the
mood that guy has really low serotonin
levels oh what oh yeah no I'm okay hey
girls quit pooping you quit pooping in
the street that's that is no thing for a
lady your age to do excuse me huh who
the hell you no you all right get right
back back to it man I'm worried about
how much time she spends just pooping up
a
storm I was talking to Dan about this
before the stream
yeah and he pointed out that shenmu
sounds like you guys are going to be
playing Shawn mooo to me
shanm it's the Shawn method you get it
surely you get that awful joke no okay
no that's a bad joke that a bad human
being would make joke well I just remade
it so I am which one of these do you
think is a Ramen SL Taylor
SL other type of store bers SHP bers
SHP oh it's my friend yep I know
you I'm worried about
you look I understand how you feel but
you really shouldn't get so involved but
I just can't let this thing go well at
least be careful the pun finally hit the
chest I will see you later everyone
hates me for it
boo all
right all right Peter you got to be on
the lookout is this a Ramen Shop uh
someone well hello well hello how's
business God his eyes are so intense
busy I have Haka helping me out that's
one thing you guys need to pay attention
to look at the intensity of Rio's eyes
eyes relative to the intensity of
everybody else cuz his eyes are like
he's been doing about a like a ziplock
bagy full of cocaine whereas everybody
else looks like they haven't been doing
that he has turned on he is he's real
keyed up
yeah my buddy Tom
hey
hi did you come up with anything about
the men in black suits no nope no clue
whatsoever I see isn't that great under
the sea I can't help you at
all oh
Tom I'm looking for Chinese people have
you guys met Chinese people is this a
tayor yeah he bad this is the Leatherman
jacket store Leatherman jacket
Leatherman is a French
restaurant what can I get
you you look busy on the contrary let me
bother you real quick I have nothing to
live for selling as well as before what
I'm not worried about Tom's hot dogs or
that hamburger place over there the
Hamburg Place Bob's Pizzeria he's aough
he's a tough competitor God wake up dude
people talk so slow that is very
true buter
shop soda shop soda shop arcade
shop normal Cuts barber normal
Cuts just going to pop in for a quick
cut bit of a bit of a little little trim
Little Beard just the tip yeah just the
trim just the tip of the beard all right
tell me about the three blades hi hi I'm
Chinese how can help searching for
members of the three blades the three
blades real how come you know about them
talson from a e told me he said I should
ask while this conversation plays out is
that so we're going to jump to a quick
commercial break and we will be back
momentarily stay
tuned and we are back you were going to
say something no I was just going to say
hi Oh okay well you go ahead hi there
you go we're back we got a hot tip from
our friend the barber that we should go
to our other friend the other Barber so
we're going to head back down that way
the barber that was closed a moment ago
perhaps he's going to you know pull some
favors for us and unclose the barber
shop I don't know I don't know what's
going on Chinese secret ancient chin
secret the power of
friendship I think it's whoa you need to
cool it buddy hey is he popping off this
guy's trying to pop off on me I think he
better pop off right back at him hey bro
hey bro you need to cool it I'm just
going to stand here we're going to have
staring contest you like this you're
never going to get to your wife and
family I could keep I could just whoa
this guy wants to get involved you you
trying to pop off buddy step back aan
hey
what the way to Barber and hair he got a
denim apron haircut uh-huh you know
tsukushi Apartments it's across from
there across from cushi Apartments
gotcha great I'm going to go
there I'm a little disappointed that
every time you run by a machine you're
not getting a
soda thank you I mean like every time
all right now when I drink the soda I
want you to pay attention to the way he
like kind of Squints one eye really
awkwardly as if he's well you know just
use your imagination
there
I'm going to go
for a grape
soda
tight lug lug lug all right here it
comes watch the face watch the face this
is
critical here it is here it
is more
more give it to me good he like frowns a
bit before smiling at the end it hurts
so good you know it hurts him a little
bit but he loves it too much not to like
this guy no how does he know everybody's
name hello uh over to Du barber in hair
salon you you know what I heard a family
called Leu moved in around here a while
ago who sorry I I didn't hear the
details I see I punched that guy in the
face I wish I could I wish I could just
punch
anybody all right I'm going in who's
closed now
you you listen
here all
welcome how would you like your hair
today I'm not here for a haircut I came
to ask from China and you are I'm huki
of the huki dojo and Yos huki son
darling you saw it in the paper on that
snowy day ah I understand you've gone
through a lot
yes I'm looking for a Chinese man who
goes by the name land
taon and the others of the three blades
said that perhaps you'd know so taon
referred you to us well I'm a second
generation Chinese so I don't think I
can be of much help maybe they meant
your
father oh I see I see interesting he is
my father's 8 years old he's old as [__]
on the Shar in Yokohama from before the
war maybe he knows is about to fall
asleep he's been in hospital for the flu
and was just discharged yesterday he's
been through a lot so we've kept it
closed for a while is he all right oh
he's much better now wake up perhaps
he's exercising in suzume park ah suzume
Park he walks once around auu and eats
at the soba restaurant every day dude
loves so I'll try
there you give him hot noodles he'll
throw them in your face give them some
cold noodles for dipping I like that
portrait on the wall oh yeah here's a
random picture picture of a white heart
throb in this Chinese Barber Shop all
right we're going to go find uh old guy
who just had flu and probably reeks of
soba
noodles just just soba sauce just
dripping from his
pores oh it's going to be night time
look for the guy with soba spilling out
of his pocket yeah
oh oh don't mind me I just love soba so
much do you have any
so all right where's that Park where's
that Park Peter duh do you know where
the park is no dude everything looks the
same here that's that incredibly racist
what that is probably the most racist
thing you've said no I've said plenty of
more racist things than that that's true
you have hey backpack where are you
going where's Tom oh hey Tom yo hello no
I'm talking to my buddy Tom oh hello
you're way cooler than Tom try again
when you get a bit older what
damn wow she's only into Old Men I think
that was a Russian
prostitute can hope
hi do you know the way to sazum park go
straight up here turn right at the
corner by the arcade I see Jesus Tom
turn it down just a little bit
oh
delightful
got to turn right at the corner by the
arcade
whooop all right old dude where you at
you
exercising um are you D son yes I am and
you yeah who wants to know huki from the
huki I think you might have killed my
father you old turd I know what happened
to your father my
condolences what can I do what can I do
for
you I'm looking for a Chinese man who
calls himself l d three blades members
like AI ichi's toon suggested that
perhaps you might know ah you know of
the three blades I just learned about it
8 minutes ago three professions Barbers
cooks and tailor that it does did you
know that the proud Elite of these
professions were also Imperial
bodyguards oh this is so helpful prot
Emperor just tell me who killed my dad
so I can go murder godamn knives and
scissors he's been waiting for months to
tell someone the story yeah let's go
back to the matter at hand old man is
most likely a member of a Chinese Black
Market cartel or perhaps even the
Chinese Mafia would they be here in yosa
they have developed a base in the harbor
to bypass customs and expand their
activities try asking some of the
sailors in the vicinity what a
coincidence I love Sailors me too
Sailors I'll look for some Sailors huh
very much open my eyes really want oh
well you don't
say are you a sailor excuse me forgive
me could you come back a bit later I'm
pooping I'm Excuse me I'm pooping I'm
busy defecating excuse me sir do you
know where I can find some hot sailor
what do you want I have something to ask
you who the hell are you to
be this guy is so butt hurt about the
time I kicked his ass do you know
anywhere around here where Sailors hang
out don't know anything about that I
see excuse me I guess you wouldn't then
would
you oh that's just your friend yeah that
guy also
sucks you look like you know about
Sailors got a minute yeah if you want
Direction
ask somebody else dude cold as ice she
said she had a minute oh yeah yeah I got
time but if you want Direction [__] off
hey oh this guy's pretty cool do you
know where the sailors hang out around
here they hang around everywhere at
nighttime they all doesn't have any
teeth but you know where is that one
tooth hey you going to start a fight
with them oh yeah I am no way I'm not
like
you you can tell me Rio looks like
you're getting excited about it but who
wouldn't get excited about just hanging
out with some Sailors knocking back a
few maybe see where it goes from there
wor oh this kid knows where Sailors are
hey mister let's play Sorry
I kid just let me know where I can hang
out with some hot Sailors yeah oh no not
Hur again [__] no you don't talk to me
hey you were pooping before oh this guy
he knows about Mill Ary stuff lady get
out you get out of my way you go I'm
talking to my buddy yo how are
you do you know of any places where
Sailors hang out Sailors here sometimes
about their Navy stuff usually they try
and sell to me about when do they come
by it's not like they come all the time
you know I
see all right okay well that doesn't
answer my question Tom would know Tom
buddy y Tom
hey Sailors love my pickles do you know
any place where Sailors hang out hey
Rude Boy Sailors yeah I do you bet I do
they hang out at bars they always start
street fights when they're drunk you
know I'm going to fight some stand them
man which bar do they hang out at I
don't know I'm broke I can't afford to
drink look Tom you're branching off here
and thus we learn Tom's shameful secret
which is which is that he has no money
to his
name all right we're going to find a bar
that's not a bar we walked by some bars
earlier do you think that tomato shop is
a
bar yes oh look at the lighting in this
game look how the game handles it so
well excuse me what you reaching for I
see I see H interesting excuse me no I
don't have time for this I don't have
time for
this this is a that is a Chinese
restaurant a
bar where was that bar Peter dude there
all the bars look
alike should we go to a jazz club slot
house yeah oh slot
house Linda snacks
to Bar Bar T Bar here we go closed oh
it's closed great what about uh next to
our
neighbor Diamond rocks also
closed why are none of these bars open
yet oh here we go bar Yuka this looks
like a sailor bar if I've ever seen bar
and snack here we go we're going to hang
out with some Sailors maybe make some
friends get a tattoo I don't know we see
where the where the day takes us bar y
sua now loading 6:31 p.m. December 4th
1986 excuse
me oh hey Rio that dude really standing
at high level you know what I'm
saying
thanks how about a cola
sure here's this room temperature Cola
please
enjoy
don't you dare make a funny
face
so what's
up I want to meet some Sailors Sai Joan
do you know any places where Sailors
like to hang out around here you say
Sailors but you don't mean just any
sailor do you wink right try the mjq
jazz bar or heartbeats
bar all right done and done I'll stop by
again what this deal hi Rio not a
guy what's her problem you're still a
minor en son's worried you know all
right all these people just drinking by
themselves at their one person tables
this guy's casting spells this he's
talking to himself this guy has been
dead for weeks this bar is sad he keeps
ordering drinks somehow and then there's
the empty carry station over
there get me out of this
bar but seriously we have to solve this
murder let's get the hell out this and
we got to find us some Sailors in order
to solve what is even the murder that
I'm your father oh yeah that's one dad
that's one my dad got murdered by some
Sailors and now I need
to get up on some Sailors get up on some
sailor really go to town on some Sailors
here we go jazbar is why am I knocking
on this Excuse
me
yes are you a Chinese people who is it I
I'm sorry we don't open till 7: what
that's in like 2 minutes that's in 2
minutes you piece of [__] A come around
9: p.m it just literally turned s all
right so you should go play an arcade
game and then come back
okay
what
welcome we're going to go we're going to
go play an arcade game and then come
meet some Sailors or maybe just play
Arcade games depending on how much time
we have
left Sailors you don't say those are my
favorite things does Narine know about
your crippling sailor
addiction if she didn't before she does
now love you
honey
see where's the the arcade I feel feel
like
it [__] you Tom [__] you Tom hey under
the sea I never sleep everything's
better down where it's wetter I'm so
broke take it from me my name is Tom my
name is Tom that doesn't
rhyme what's happening in the chat what
sakumi say uh sakumi said best bar ever
although at least I had a single girl
sitting
alone a you creepy creepy dude
all right what's it going to be what's
the one in the in the the far left I
know we got space Harrier right
there excite GTE QT oh quick time one
game 100 no I'm not going to play a qte
game not when I've got hang on
and and qte title qte
title space Harrier 100 y a
game
I'll try it sun Feld in the chat wants
to know what's this game about walking
around like a fool looks boring it's
about life man it's about life and also
Sailors yeah well primarily Sailors
mostly Sailors it's a simulator a sailor
simulator not a sailor Simulator more
like it simulates the act of really
wanting to hang out with Sailors welcome
to searching for sailor
simulator what am I doing Peter uh you
are shooting everything that you can
muster the courage and ability to
shoot give me give me the historical
context for this game so space areer
this is one of sega's early arcade games
uh it is also similar to Galaxy cors
another series that came out uh on uh
the I don't want to say the wrong
Hardware unless see model one system
people are going to tear you apart
they're going to tear me apart I know I
know there was a sequel both games came
out in the Genesis and it is a favorite
of gentlemen at Platinum Games Kamia
Kamia
son uh I believe he has an arcade
machine in his apartment why do I know
what in his apartment don't ask this is
a different a very unique style of
shooter purely in terms of like the
camera angle oh yeah it's definitely
different get ready get
ready I believe this is a part of the
arcade version not the Genesis Port he
also supported the Master System Oh
no I got killed by a giant face
dragon or you can enter your initials
right don't enter my initials oh you're
out of rank I'm out of rank oh should we
try hang on you want to try hang on yeah
yeah yeah you try hang on thank you I
thought you'd never ask give hang on a
shot hang on hang on
on you get
hung let me see the laptop this
controller seen better days yeah it's a
little gross little grimy a little Frank
grimy sake Tumi says it's not an RPG if
you don't have stats and level up well
the stats in this game are how many
times you hang out with Sailors and you
level up the more times you hang out
with Sailors so really you're just
hanging out with Sailors I'll try it and
leveling up to get more
points just the one just the one maybe
just the
one sler says Sean didn't win that was
my very first time playing space Harrier
in my life since I played
shenmo the
original the OG shenmu the OG they did a
HD re-release of this at one point
Didn't They for like xpla uh I don't
think so no I think that they actually
started or they have created HD ports of
this and shimu 2 oh
cool yeah so this you got to hold hold
up on the analog stick as your like
default oh
otherwise otherwise you kind of like hit
right and you stay going to the right
this ises not control really
well ah I'm going to use the notorious
bib says shenmu is actually Japanese
from hanging with Sailors that's
true see it h
Sailors anybody just tuning in now we're
still playing shenmu it's just we're in
the arcade that lets you play classic
Sega games this is hang on a game that y
Suzuki made right I believe he was
involved yes he was involved well he
didn't make it with his own bare hands
but that you mean
literal bare
hands yeah he was involved in the
creation of hang on and space
Harrier oh yeah this game's tough
especially with these controls yeah the
music is so good oh look how far you got
not very far nope enter your initials I
won't do
it I'll do it so you do it with the
triggers for some
reason I don't know why
um cool
cool all right let's find some Sailors
I'm going find I'm going to find some
Sailors we got 10 minutes to find some
Sailors and you better believe we're
going to find some
Sailors here we
go my biggest fear when playing old
games on dis is that at some point the
loading screen is just going to stay
there
and then you're just going to be screwed
it happened this
morning
so keep those fingers crossed I just
don't want to miss out on any sailor
action yeah no this Dreamcast is a lot
louder than I remember it being yeah
there's a lot of woring and grinding
going on in there okay here we go with
purpose nope that is a different
place game
you
is it 9:00 yet it's not 9:00 yet but
it's getting to be 9:00 Tom just appears
as if an apparition sent from the
heavens maybe I should pop into this uh
convenience
store
in I need to buy some Japanese candies
like those little koala bear ones that
have chocolate on the insides and uh but
you know the great thing about community
stores in Japan is that they carry
everything yeah you can buy a new shirt
and tie there yep you can buy you you
certainly have got a minute oh this lady
if you want directions ask somebody El
you know if she had taken the time just
to tell you where to go at this point
she would she could have avoided these
conversations what
what do you know anywhere that Sailors
hang out yes foreigners come here
sometimes but I don't know if they're
Sailors I
see this town is just filled with
helpful people you people are all
terrible gobu Riot says have you been to
Japan Peter and Sean yes we have both
been to Japan I have been four four
times I've been like
seven or eight times I don't know you
lose count you lose count you do you
literally do let's see uh yeah Japan is
what the hell is this what the hell what
what's going on here hey guys we're
live what you guys just going to
interrupt the stream we're just going to
interrupt our stream just to do your
lobby promo oh oh okay all right no
that's fine that's fine that's fine
that's fine we understand we understand
it's not like we're live
on the internet we're looking for
Sailors online we're not like just
constantly looking for Sailors and
shenmu or anything nobody was here
nobody would believe you nobody was here
I think they wanted our swi uh Danny
owire just just burst into the studio
right now to shoot a promo for the lobby
classic owire classic Danny uh where's
where's my uh S Bar oh you oh pull it
your uh your sailor Compass do you oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you have a Jeffrey I have a Jeffrey yeah
look at this who needs some Sailors yeah
you want some Sailors come get some of
this oh
yeah look at
this get
sailed okay we're going to find some
Sailors where is the bar I lost the bar
[__] that's where the girls were
pooping maybe you should ask that lady
for directions no that lady is the
literal worst she is a human
monster it's dark and scary at night I
hear dogs
barking that's the Tomato shop oh it's
9:00 okay here we go good call I think
this is the jazz bar
yeah here we
go I'm looking for Sailors hey where can
I find some Sailors preferably ch
Chinese
Sailors and also do you guys have any
advice on being better at hang on and
space Harrier cuz I'm real bad at it
space carrier space
Harrier look at these
Sailors what a real bunch of sailors
what a bunch of
sailors oh yeah this bar is classy as
[__] talk about
jazz got a minute what do we look like
sailors the kid saying
something are you guys
Sailors could be could be Hey kid how
about a game of Lucky hit game you sink
the ball in one shot you win and I'll
answer your questions all right and then
some other stuff I and you got to answer
my questions
okay oh yeah you're on just have to make
the shot right try your luck
whoa he threw that just so vertically so
gingerly so
gingerly why am I shooting one Q ball at
another q
ball oh that's an that's an eight ball
that's a nine ball my friend that's a
nine
ball I can't there's actually no way to
aim you seem to be doing a really good
job right now here we go oh now I can
aim it this looks good
wait wait wait wait great
success
unbelievable man the deal was I make the
shot and you tell me what I want to know
now who's a sailor are you guys
Sailors nah we're base
workers Sailors drink at the heartbeat
spot [__] dude you're constantly getting
the run around hey let's bet again come
on not if you're not a sailor I only
mess with with Sailors you guys go screw
yourselves I guess it's fitting that the
sailors are at the heartbeats bar that
makes sense yeah Sailors are where the
heart is okay and the butt heartbeats
bar we're going to find those Sailors
we've only got 3 minutes but we're going
to at least find some Sailors where's
the heartbeats bar
Peter that way excuse me lady you look
like a
sailor got a minute I have something to
do now let's talk later you have nothing
to do you're standing out out front of
this bar close your mouth and you're
just like huddling that's weird
heartbeat
bar I think it's actually it might even
be around this corner I'm just saying
that
actually heartbeats bar I have no
special
knowledge heartbeats
bar bar
Linda bar Linda
snacks knocking motorcycle
shop seems like a good shop good name
for a shop English is hard man
heartbeats
bar nope which if you were a bar called
heartbeats bar where would you be well I
can tell you what I would look like it's
it almost had like a neon sign like um
the bar
Yokosuka it's got to be in that little
stretch right yeah the bar stretch
little bar stretch got to be around here
yeah our pizza
par
that was like spelled
out just looking for some neon signage
that's the bar that we were just
in where are the sailors
Peter those elusive sexy Sailors bar
yasuka it's the heartbeats bar oh that's
the Ramen Shop is this the heartbeats
bar no that's that's Diamond
Rock right all we need to do is just
find the dumb heartbeats bar where do
you guys in the chat know where is the
heartbeats bar Peter I'll use my GPS use
your GPS I'm going to talk to this guy
um what do you want Sailors I need to
ask you something I got nothing to say
to you really oh opposite the motorcycle
shop you think you're talking to you
you
so go to the knocking motorcycle shop
which should be right there and then
down the stairs across the way which is
down here oh
hey we're going to end this stream with
some Sailors on a hot note on a hot on a
hot sailor
note oh
uh-oh look at these
guys they're probably Sailors you guys
Sailors or zombies I can't really you
guys know where I can find some sailor
get out of my way oh
[__]
what go
home hey you I'm a
sailor these aren't the sailors you're
looking for these aren't the sailors
you're looking
for sailor bar we found the sailors do
you think those guys are sailors or were
they trying to protect the sailors from
Rio they're trying to protect their pack
of sailors yeah these are our Sailors
you hear cuz everybody knows that you
don't let Rio around those Sailors whoa
look at this sailor bar yeah what's up
Sailors you guys like to
sail here you go milk's perfect for a
school boy how did he already have that
ready did he just have like milk behind
the bar ready just plop down and I'm
looking for work with Chinese ships tell
what are you some kind of TV detective
or something back off what are you some
kind of Sailor or
something you looking for some of this
oh no you get
decked you get
bubbled you
stupid who's a
now that's
enough you put on quite a show boy I'm
look a fight with
some that was great I'll tell you what
in return you don't show your face here
again but you have all the yeah so it's
going to be hard to keep me away from
this place he deals in smuggled Goods
he's well known in the Underworld he
should know about the Chinese
cartel where is
he he loves his hog e try asking at
theot shop nearby what's he look
like he always wears Shades in a black
leather jacket oh yeah that's
distinguishable he's got a tattoo on his
arm a real low resolution tattoo it
looks like a real smeared out Dragon get
out all right so we came yeah we found
what we were looking for we found some
Sailors we got into a fight y uh got
into a couple fights uh I feel like that
was a pretty successful altercation with
some Sailors not bad for Tuesday morning
not bad for a Tuesday morning hey
everybody thanks for watching this
episode of the Sha method next week on
Tuesday at 11:00 a.m. Pacific we'll be
back with another episode watch dogs but
before that Monday 11:00 a.m. meab bit
where I'm playing a mysterious old game
that I haven't decided on yet it'll be
fun it'll be great and make sure to tune
into the lobby today at uh 2:00 Pacific
time which is in just two hours yes so
don't go anywhere we've got a lot of
cool stuff coming your way take it
easy